You know. So. Nine hundred seventy four. I was living in new england platter. And lots of people traveling from.
From name been. To sydney would go. By the back road.
And stay at their place overnight so i used to get lots of news about what was happening in yemen.
In the setting up a tunnel. And it was part of me.
They wanted to go back and fulfill the promise that we made at the public meeting we said. Had said that.
The name and the. Christmas would bring young people back to the town and. Repopulate the area. And revitalize it.
And it's turned into a slogan by the way the architecture student that we would recycle nimbin we would recycle a town
and. I could see it was happening and slowly. I wanted to go along and. Bob it up so.
We got an invitation from a group called the educational smorgasbord. Which was kind of based the bell and it was a.
Gordon lang that was a retired primary school teacher got some money from the school's commission at that stage to
develop. Community learning. And we had some expertise at that from that.
The festival learning exchange that happened at the pfister we had a model for doing that.
So rather than take a job as an individual life. I think formed a partnership with a couple of people including chance.
Who's one of the site manager of the festival the guy most responsible for the physical. Works on the festival.
We formed a company called the reality construction company. And how job was the gun.
You know turned myths into reality. We were going to create this new community. New future is. You newman and.
We were all about flesh and flea and. Doing it with style. And sort of.
Feeling that the name when it would become a big gumboot. You know sort of lost in the mud.
Because all of the limits that the people who founded tumble. And did some one of them are syringes conditions that.
Fifty people living in a single house you know. In the heaviest rains. Who are you know sort of twenty is.
It was disparate. Times and.
No money no money to do any development work to buy the tools materials think you know a lot. And lots of madness.
And lots of people coming in plugging in and wanting help and what kind of stuff. Also cites. You know.
This strange mixture of piny as and parasites and. Sites and. Paranoids you know like weeds the the the.
The vision of collected. So we came back to name and first we sort of. Caressed into name been lifted you people.
And that the company was working. Kind of blew apart.
The reality construction company never actually got to him and blew apart in linux he had.
Gordon lange wouldn't made a set up in him because he didn't want them. To be polluted by the aquarius dream.
He went into question small was would this be seen as kind of straight.
It was kind of ironic the only people interested in these new ideas were the hippies of course that. So it was.
We did a couple of good things including two or yellow brick road show us. Nigel trivets theatre in education piece.
Anyway we blew apart and i ended up living in human again. And working with my partner. On community development.
And what what became obvious to us immediately was that.
What we'd taken for granted well organized and you crystal clear this festival had been forgotten.
People who example didn't know that you could hire the whole to have a public meeting. You know.
There's so much antagonism a great. Between the people who stayed after the festival and the townspeople.
But the fists the community services were seen things being withheld and not available to people.
So are we realized that. Building this community was going to be grassroots work and.
In the beginning of it was like learning how to have meetings again. Learning him. How to have community meetings.
One of the legacies of the queerest festival was that the festival had acquired property in the main street of member.
I mention the are still whole have been purchased by the festival net was sold after the festival to a group of people
who said that they were going to stay behind and. You know some of them were already owning property and.
That the building would be there for community function. And we sure would that there was a sufficient spirit of.
I don't know this that. Can never be sold. Right no one could be everyone had to agree to sell it.
And there's no way these people would ever agree. The rainbow cafe the lease and the rainbow cafe.
Was extended and they cannot by the tunnel force cooperative. And my partner.
Purchased the tomato sauce factory which was an old general store. In the one street.
And these people were all available for. Community business. Specifically for the new settlers. This.
Contrast to what was happening over at my naaman mullumbimby where the people had settled in the hills in the valley.
And around there and had no presence. To speak of in the town.
Niman always always had a shop front present for the new settlers. Now. This was an advantage.
The poor the early community development organization because we had a central place to organize services from the.
The the media factory was what we called the are still. Whole. Became a healing center. Right and swear. Carol.
Elliott no one stand up and the first acupuncture practice on the north coast. Just.
Message was offered the and who will treat treatments. And also became the center for organizing.
The birth and beyond group the. Sort of the home birthing unit. That came later.
Well we said in the back of the media factory and had.
The first meetings of what was to become the home builders association because it became aware that the.
Designing the land zoning. Was not what people wanted.
People want to divide the land and allow other people to build houses on it. So there was lots of land available.
Very cheaply. But the zoning required you can only build one house behinder dicked is.
Now people are already building their houses by seventy full on these properties and are legal.
So the home builders association was formed to negotiate with the council about changing the zoning. And.
The first meeting so this home builders association were. About learning how to have meetings. And this was critical.
Because what had happened was that. Everyone had a piece of the dream. That had been seeded by the curious fistful.
But no foreign forth. So when the former's created. Everyone came in mauritius vomited. Their frustration.
In the dream onto the meeting. There was lots of talk but no listening.
So we had to work very hard at the stablish ing.
Ways of having meetings in basically the format of sitting in a circle. Having introductions everyone spoke.
Went around the circle everyone spoke. Introduce themselves and said what are the meaningful.
And then we would set the agenda. From what had come up. And then we would talk right. And just require.
Some moderation as a whole argument that structure.
Was a part of would have a channel with stuff would quickly you know with.
Cheering it round but basically there was someone who said. You're speaking too much you're considered think you're.
Someone took responsibility for the meeting.
Now having established the rules and having established the process of listening to people. We moved very quickly.
And the home builders association was an enormously successful negotiating body. We got membership.
All over the place i mean. That was one of the stories about the home builders association.
Like all good voluntary associations we needed some money to spend so we decided we'd have to have a benefit concert.
We had the benefit concert we realized there were no musicians.
Right chris and introduced lots of musicians to get into the area. But they weren't playing together.
So we only had a couple of people singing songs with guitars you know. But it's still a good thing but.
Out of that result. We've got to do something about the music because this is also our priority. So i was.
We were approached by a group who want to set up a folk love in the matter saw it
and we said well this is this what we've been waiting for so we. You know.
My partner and i thrust support behind the folk line. And the folk love. Took off like a rocket.
All these people came out and started playing the music together.
And listening to each other and forming new combinations and rehearsing
and practicing bringing you songs to the to the. The folk club.
Suddenly there was a flowering of music in the been and.
Such that
when we came to do the knicks been a fit for the home builders association which was only like three months down the
track.
We had thought of different combinations of musicians fighting for the states you know this is all voters you know
people saying oh we want to fly rehearse this for you.
So that was the kind of organization was going on at the time and the name in news we started up.
The new news with sort of a running through skep staple publication and. We introduced. Rules which were no censorship.
You could say what your life. But you had to put your name on it yet to own what you wrote. Arguing that. That.
The village was so small that.
You know people would get immediate feedback of this in an outrageous from the people they defended. We could afford.
And since it had no capital we didn't we weren't. Obligated by need. Defamation laws or anything like that. You know.
No one was at risk will the individuals be at risk but certainly not the publication of the assets of zero and.
The name in news was the most fascinating publication.
I've seen at the time i've been the editor of student publications we get the strangest. You know.
Made right moves and. Sort of birth notices that people are calling the a still.
Manga sunshine you have to remember sunshine and things like this with the most delightful news. Would appear in this.
And always incredibly immediate and this used to come out weekly
and it was enormously bonding thing so the home bill's association had in effect it had its own.
News organ that got out to all the people building.
About what was happening with the negotiations which started with the council on my own feeling was a soon as we had
established and ago she a sion with the council. We were certainly going to win.
Rights as soon as we'd sent the negotiation home builders put out to everyone stop building like crazy.
Because everything that is built will be approved. When the new zoning comes in at least that will win that much.
So this rapidly lead to confrontation.
That
when the council became a widow which was won by this time the lismore city council became aware of how extensive the
illegal building was was that was happening in the hills they wanted to put the brakes on.
And get pull at the borders as. Well at this time. Things begin to move very quickly.
It was like felt like a golden period with this seemed to be like nothing that we could do that. Wasn't magical.
We had both we had folk loans we had concerts. Slim dusty came to town. And working the main street of the infinite.
You know you know slim dusty. Yeah yeah. Good to meet you. You know. We're playing it. You know.
And they are sometimes we thought when drop drop. We we had a little just before the festival.
We were invited to play at the festival it was a lovely letter from. Maybe you know. By tool.
I bought two of my partner. From your noa sure do want to come to dinner and come and meet violet. Would like that.
And that you know. Slim.
So i'm just enjoying it came just lovely people who travel in country towns will realise this love this.
So they came out with a band and had dinner with us
and we say well why don't you know you've got a night off tomorrow night.
Why don't you come to a concert in the nimon home that played in the name of whole one time or other.
And with the folk like this guest of the folk club.
So he's in the twenty four hours to organise this this concert with featuring slim dusty in the in the.
The best of the folk club. And it was the most amazing concert. Like the folk.
Everyone from the folk club will perform was just shining that night
and all the townspeople turned out to see this di slim dusty and. Slim dusty performed it was just. It meant.
There's one of us. Those nights. And we had naming ceremonies and we had.
Healing festivals that all this kind of stuff.
And for me the principle of community organization which i was doing
and sharing with lots of other people was creating events where people could experience the joy of community that.
What they believed in was affirmed in the experience of joy together she had julie. So not at the folk club.
I don't remember crying. The song. There was some.
It was both the quality of the music in the voice but also in the sentiments that people were seeing to each other.
We grew very quickly very tight as a community and. Established. Like i say. The norms for the.
Unity the expectation is that the extraordinary things happened in women.
And there were lots of the bites of it between vegetarians in these and all this kind of stuff.
But as if the dreams that have been seeded by the queerest festival. Begin to take. Form in community.
And there were sufficient. Concentration of people to carry these values. Into everyday life and make them realities.
So that. For example. Everything back to the birth and beyond group.
It was only a matter of time before people started having babies and families. Developing me.
And the healings center was called upon to help with the birth things. And carol. Carol's more.
Psychic thinner than a medical. Medically trained people.
Person but entered into this in the healing training for record pension. In good faith.
And good will and with lots of support from people.
Build up this birth and be on movement and birth became a spiritual experience. Such that people.
Preferred to have home births. Than go to the lismore base hospital in the labor ward. Now.
They were outcries of course from the doctors and because the theatre and all this kind of stuff.
But the end result was that the labor ward in lismore changed. That i made the birthing process is much more humane.
Much more people scented. You know. By a.b.c. Entered. Than had previously been.
And the principles of spiritual midwood three of which you've been introduced through the new settlers in women.
Became integrated in hospital practice in lisbon.
So it's like that they need to be a concentration of people who willing to have home birth wanted the service.
And once that was established and influence lots of other people as well. And then. Attitudes towards trees.
The area of the settled by white people first.
The first was people came to syria to cut down trees in the city to get us into. The primeval forest.
First took the cedar. And then it was divided. The selection.
The blocks the land was sold down south and when the conditions was that people come up here and. Clear their land.
To create. Us. So very quickly. An extensive rainforest. Would from a cost to forty kilometers inland. The normal size.
Including the tweed valley. Right down to the richmond. Was almost wiped out and set up the dairy farms.
The new settlers coming to the area had a completely different attitude to trees they had been influenced by the goal
of the movement.
Things like that so even
when we're preparing for the fish we were proposed by people from the borders ranges saying are you aware what's
happening at the ranges. The border ranges to look one of the remnants of the big scrub.
And by night one seventy four people are aware of the logging practices were happening on the night kept range this
behind him and. Where the the. The loggers were just leaving a sort of a curtain of trees by the road.
And almost clear filling the property
but on the hillsides under supervision of the force of commission which was at the time calling it selective looking
which was take anything of value and drop the lot.
When we were first approached about this with a sense of frustration what can we do.
Right we're organizing fist of all and. We don't have them. The way with a lot of organized protest the same time.
But by. Nine hundred seventy six. Like.
It was a community concern about what was happening with the logan and then it erupted.
At the battle of trying to create in the situation was that the new settlers.
Had moved into the area in the drainage creeks when the creeks it runs into the channel.
And it's like two valleys across from going. East. Going west. Sorry.
Going east from nimbin it's like two valleys across. And then he went one road up the creek and.
At the end of the creek was fifty hc to force which was enclosed by rock. On the other side so that.
Part of the reason that it had such old trees in it was that. Previous technologies. It was an inaccessible.
And the brush box wasn't valued. For all that much but now the force the commission. Decided that that.
Forest had to go to live in a lot of brush books.
And the residents complained about the destruction the forest
and i also pointed out that they didn't want these logging trucks. On the road there's only one right.
And they were entered in negotiations with the forest commission and they came to the zilch. The first missions.
Of the force of the following. You can sense that we don't care and replied lismore city council was to put up signs.
I'm with the residents. Beware of logging trucks. Not. You know.
So and i'm at the logging truck saying people are is going to take kids.
But they came for you to chosen to live here and you'll suffer. If you don't take notice of that log loading trucks.
So it was like a slap in the face no negotiations came to nothing. The people who are negotiating that. Decide.
Protests was called for and they approached me and other people. For assistance in transforming. A committee meeting.
Into a public protests and i joined the protests that that study aids
and i didn't ever want to become involved in any more committees that have been committed up to my ears for long.
You know. Moving. And i. I went along for the role i want to play with like sharman. I want to just work on the energy.
That hell would hold a group of people together who certainly thought it would draw a crowd. And we created a bit of.
Theater which was performed at the the china market using biggie midges and music. To tell the story. Of the proteus.
And to announce the people there would be a meeting at the forest. The following wednesday and.
The bit of theater was very graphic. Big media is dancing around and. Kind of mystical.
Big crosas adult man with kind of stuff. So it's almost signs.
Moving in and the following wednesday we had a meeting at the site and. The leaders of the. The festival.
How do you turn this into a unified group of people are going to work together. And kids. The impulse.
Of committee people just to stand out from the crowd and talk at them. You know. And i'm saying well.
There's other ways to do it. And one of the things to do is to complete the circle.
Get people to see the circus of written get a circle happening.
We've got the grounds where real communication can happen. And with a bit of music in the systems from friends.
We completed the circle.
And it went from being a disparate people not knowing whether they should be there or whether they were present.
To a group of people sitting down. Planning a protest. And trusting each other just everything the basic trust.
So it was that circles. Tribal circles became sort of a fundamental ingredient to. The first protests. That happened.
On the winds day. And the following monday it was a council meeting in. Reasonable.
With a buddy famines but he thought it was one of the only communities.
That had announced that it was going to build regardless. You know. It was doing the morally correct thing.
It was providing. Low cost accommodation to house people.
So they can raise the thing only and no lore in the land should prevent people from doing that.
So they took a totally moral stand and.
Let the council know what they were doing working with the hundreds of the social. And that would determine to be.
The pivot. You know the test case. They'd incorporated themselves as a church. In a ready to fight.
As an ethical community. Doing what was right in the times and. The council conceded their case that night.
And these national party. Councils got up and said things like breaking a little.
Advocate that we knocked down the house as soon as possible.
And in the gallery of the body thumbs with the baby's line how do you know it was like a classic.
You know this like a peasant class this is the new pool. You know.
Totally i think i'm clearly clear about what they want to do. Against this with these. Rantings of these ageing.
Community leaders who had no regard no compassion. Whatsoever for the people.
So for me it was obvious that the battle for the forest. And the battle for the houses were one of the same.
If we lost the trees we'd certainly lose the houses because they disposed us that houses in the same way they build us
the trees. So the name in news put that missy jaffe. You know. To everyone. This was it. This was crunch time.
On the wednesday. After that meeting. The bulldozers. Arrived at the forest they came down via a back road. The.
The telephone tree worked and we. You know within an hour we had about one hundred people gathered at the forest.
And the images. That would have been used in the play would vote to be. And took great pride in.
Putting the dollar manny means on top of the bulldozer. And it became the icon the sydney morning herald used to.
And that sort of died a report of this protest. And we stopped the vote as it was any measure of time. You know the.
More police and more reinforcements were coming and it was a big showdown the minister for. Forests.
Was totally against the hippies he was from. Griffith.
Any writing his local newspaper that he was going to do is you know we printed that article. You know. Moralist saying.
They're just rabble rousing hippies and we haven't taken notice of them. We printed that.
Poured in the name when you simply want to know what we're up against and. Raise the ire of the people.
And created this community. Now we brought all our cultural resources to bear on that proteus.
The musicians from the folk on time and. Wrote anthems. First the seeing. The healers were there to help people.
All the communication skills we developed and home builders association reply and coming to agreements.
And the community was strong and i remember the day that the police reinforcements arrived and there. They had people.
From as far as newcastle rusted on duty.
To do the show when they came along and i was psyched up the police were aggressive i really got a roll of us you know.
And we were still we had a circle. At the camp that morning and.
We have been lots of discussions but basically we had been i would agree what we were going to do. Run.
It was lots of tension lots of theater in the circle and. No clear direction.
And we stood together holding in the circle holding close oms into the. Intertwined and took off.
And this one was slow sublime. So strong. You could feel the spirit. Lifting us up before her. That seven.
And i'm on my knees buckled. I just couldn't stand. T. Is streaming down high. My eyes. But that.
One thing was obvious that we were in the spirit that. Strong in the spirit. We would be together.
And we would defend the forest and we would win. It was clear. And. So we yielded before the. The police attack.
They they just bonsor they pushed through our lines. They pushed away the obstacle was in the bulldozers.
Plowed through the forest appearing road to take the logs out. But we studied that right.
And then it became obvious that happiness of your answer is going to win the battle. Like.
The longer we stay that was costing the police. Tapes. The thing the state government.
They were playing the police overtime they put him in motels all is going to stuff.
Whereas we were living in our home country this was the battle of the same thing through a ride with the invading force.
We are in the hills and. Said people would bring in supplies or bring his food. We had a camp kitchen. Cooperate.
Cooking. It was the thing with the query festival over again. Right.
We were seen enjoying us hills and dancing and talking and. Sitting around campfires. We were very good at this.
So for four weeks. We maintain this presence in the forest and pressure on the loading operations and.
As time went by we became stronger and stronger. And as time went by the police became weaker and weaker.
As a defense force.
For the low
but it's because every day they talk to these most battles of sitting around doing nothing so the police are sitting in
the forest. Saying this is a really nice force. And he said you know.
What a message and so in the end it was like the police wouldn't allow loading trucks to go out without god's wrath.
Without a convoy of police cars and policeman.
Which took a long time to organize so that the logging operation was incredibly slow down as well. And.
So it was that them. A moratorium. Was called naval rent change his position.
In talking about it why would he cause you through with. You know.
He'd be repetitious we moved from concerned to describe me as a city rep a concern conservationists within two weeks
rising. Suddenly realize there were votes in. Conservation and called a halt to the operation. And an inquiry which.
We knew in the forest. We knew we'd won. And it took two years. The state government.
To acknowledge that they went to logan forest they were gay and. It was going to become a state. So we won.
And because of the heat. That was generated by the battle. When it came to the housing issue.
The state government stepped in when we have to say look we won the forest and then they got to get us.
And like that the houses. Pull landers at that time the minister the late poor man that was used to the planning.
Stepped in and employed coal james the planner of the. Chris this table.
To come up with a solution to the zoning problem which led to multiple occupancy. Dwellings up here.
So it was as if we went from a very short time.
Post the queries first of all when the community was weak and disparate with a vision and.
Committed work from a number of people to create a sense of community
and she did that years into a community that was strong enough to take on the first. Commission.
And completely reverse. Attitudes to looking in the area. The battle of tyranny creek with the thirst successful.
Rainforest things in australia. The people who fought that fought went down to the franklin and.
Taught people not nonviolent action. So there were a major influence in the way that the. The the franklin.
Was fought the. The people also not kept range which is the one looking women.
A couple of years later and then of a she lost. This you.
Was defended and the knight kept range which was the last major pocket of rainforest of the big screen.
Was turned into a national park.
So within a short time from i would say from seventy four through to seventy i had a sense of community had been
created that was strong enough to defend the values of the community. And make them real.
And it had went from strength to strength from then on i think. You look at a number of influences on the north coast.
And trace them to a.
It is that we've had some expression in the news in the newman festival of seventy three taking things taking shape his
community practice. And then influence from the wider community. One that interim influences.
Interest me in particular is attitude toward social change. Non-violent social action.
And what i was talking about before but. Learning to have meetings together learning to have a fictive meetings.
Has now become taking the stage at first the developed into despair and empowerment. Workshops on.
People learning skills to develop. Ways of handling. Resisting the nuclear holocaust. You know.
Noting down the plough she is. How to do this in the world's going to. Into this here it came this.
The idea of expressing this big. One of the waste of the expressed the spirit and out of the spear.
And the doing that collectively.
Would come agreements and people being able to work together to make a difference in their lives. In the communities.
When that. Those ideas combined with. Rainforest action id's.
We've got the council of all beings which join seeds and join and i see write a book called. Thinking like a man.
Which was that is a kind of a ritual where people can express.